Will the deeply unpopular ban on unlocking smartphones be short-lived?
On the heels of the White House, receiving more than 100,000 signatures...
...to make unlocking cell phones legal again,...
...the Federal Communications Commission is ready to evaluate the ban.
FCC chairman Julius Genachowski told TechCrunch quote,...
"It's something that we will look at the FCC..."
"...to see if we can and should enable customers to use unlocked phones."
In January, the Library of Congress modified the Digital Millennium Copyright Act...
...to make it illegal for consumers to unlock mobile phones...
...to enable them to switch carriers mid-contract.
Consumer groups have argued the ban on unlocking is detrimental to competition and innovation.
While Genachowski's comments are encouraging,...
...it's not clear the FCC has authority to change how the new rules are enforced.